redondear 24 a 1.259 a la centena más
cercana a la centena más cercana y
podrás ver que al realizar estos
problemas resultarán bastante simples
pero que quiero en realidad hacer es
pensar que significa el redondear a la
centena más cercana así que déjame
realizar una línea recta por aquí abajo
y en la cual vamos a ir dibujando o
marcando la centenas sobre dicha línea
así que vamos a suponer que por aquí
tenemos el 24 1100 luego por acá tenemos
24 1200 luego 24 mil 300 y finalmente 24
mil 400 y espero que veas a lo que me
refiero cuando hablo de ir incrementando
en centenas y bueno ahora sobre esta
línea donde se encontraría el 24 mil 259
y al observar dicha línea vemos que
queda más cerca de 24 mil 200 que es de
24 mil 300 así que por aquí tendríamos
en este
punto en este intervalo de las centenas
y justo en este punto tendríamos el 24
mil 259 así que cuando alguien te
pregunte cómo redondear a la centena más
cercana ellos literalmente se están
refiriendo a que redondee es a alguno de
estos incrementos de 100 o redondear a
cualquier incremento de 100 que le quede
más cerca y si miras algo como esto si
simplemente le echas un ojo de hecho
puedes observar que está más cerca del
24.300 que de 24.200 así que cuando lo
redondea los redondeadas al 24 1300 por
lo que si redondas a la centena más
cercana la respuesta literalmente es 24
mil 300 y ahora este tipo de comprensión
conceptual del por qué es llamada la
centena más cercana le diremos
comprendiendo y bien no todo el tiempo
cuando realizó este tipo de problemas es
necesario utilizar esta recta pero si tú
así lo prefieres está bien solo que
existe otro proceso quizás un poco más
fácil
más mecánico que será fijarnos en este
número 24 1.259 y fijarnos que dígito
ocupa el lugar de las centenas que en
este caso nuestro lugar de las centenas
lo ocupa el número 2 y al decir que
queremos redondear es que no queremos
que haya ningún otro dígito a su derecha
del lugar que ocupan en este caso las
centenas queremos que estos dígitos sean
0 y bien entonces nos vamos a fijar en
el dígito que está a la derecha del
número 2 en este caso se de la centena y
para cuando son 5 o números mayores a 5
vamos a redondear hacia arriba así que
redondeamos hacia arriba en esta
situación pues nuestro dígito que está a
la derecha de la centena es 5 y dijimos
que para redondear hacia arriba eran
cinco mayores cristales y mayores me
refiero al 6
de 8 o 9 así que este número lo vamos a
redondear a la siguiente centena que
sería 24 mil 300 y esto es a lo que me
refiero cuando decimos que redondeamos
hacia arriba y ahora por poner un
ejemplo contrario vamos a poner la
cantidad de 24 mil 249 y de la misma
forma nos fijamos en nuestras centenas
que el mismo número 2 lo vuelve a ocupar
y al fijarnos en nuestro dígito de la
derecha ahora es el número 4 y el lugar
de las centenas ahora no es igual o
mayor que 5 así que lo que vamos a hacer
es redondear hacia abajo y cuando digo
redondea hacia abajo debemos de tener
cuidado pues esto no significa decrecer
completamente el número que ocupa la
centena más bien nos vamos a reducir
nuestra centena más bien sería para
24.200 que es la centena más próxima a
249 y esto tiene sentido pues nos vamos
a la recta nuestro 24 1.249 se situaría
más o menos por aquí por esto
punto que acabo de situar y te das
cuenta ahora sí 24 mil 249 queda más
cerca de 24 mil 200 que es nuestro
primer ejemplo y listo